hey what's up everyone it's Warren and
Captain Marvel was awesome I'll be doing
a review on it later on but right now
let's go ahead and break down those post
credits scenes also a quick reminder I'm
still doing my IMAX giveaway if you
would like to enter for your chance to
win five IMAX tickets so you and some
friends can go see Avengers endgame in
IMAX
all you have to do is subscribe to my
channel like this video and comment down
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero or villain okay
spoiler alert if you do not want to know
anything about Captain Marvel and the
post-credit scenes click away now okay
if you're still with me during Captain
Marvel we see Nick Fury give Carol
Danvers a pager at the end of the movie
we see her give him the pager back but
it has been upgraded with alien
technology and she tells him that it is
now capable of reaching her in other
galaxies flash-forward to the post
credit scene of Avengers infinity war
this is the same pager that we see Nick
Fury use right before he turns to dust
so as everybody was turning to dust Nick
Fury ran to get his pager to call in
Captain Marvel because we know that she
is his last resort we learned from the
Captain Marvel prelude comic that Nick
Fury would only call in Carol Danvers if
the Avengers couldn't do the job
so in the post-credits scene of Avengers
infinity war everybody is dying and Nick
Fury calls in Captain Marvel right
before turning to dust and the pager
falls on the ground then in the
post-credits scene for Captain Marvel we
see the pager hooked up to some sort of
machine it's blinking and then it stops
then cuts to Captain America and Black
Widow who are looking at a screen that
is telling them the death toll of
everybody who died due to the snap then
we see war machine come in the
background and tell them that the thing
stopped doing whatever it was doing it
is clear that these remaining Avengers
are at the Avengers headquarters and
it's also clear that they have no idea
what this pager is we then see a scene
with Captain America black widow war
machine and Bruce Banner looking at the
pager Banner says that it was sending a
signal and then it finally stopped
Captain America is confused about why it
stopped because they now have it plugged
into where it doesn't need a battery war
machine confirms that it is plugged in
but it still just stopped
Captain America says reboot it so it
signals again but Bruce Banner steps in
and says we don't even know what this is
but Black Widow cuts in and says
fury did just do it please obviously
natasha has worked right alongside with
fury for many many years and is one of
the people that she trusts the most
so since Nick Fury is one of the people
that she trusts the most she trusts that
whatever device this is it's for good
she then tells him tell me when you get
a signal I want to know who's on the
other side of that thing she turns
around to leave and right when she turns
around she sees Captain Marvel standing
right in front of her in which Captain
Marvel says where's fury and then of
course it says Captain Marvel will
return in Avengers in game so there are
a few things to note about this
post-credit scene one is that this
happens really early on in avengers
endgame we know this because Captain
America still has his beard and they're
tallying the deaths of all the people
who fell victim to the snap still
another thing that is very clear is that
the pager is blinking until Captain
Marvel shows up and when the pager stops
in the post-credits scene that is
because she has arrived at the Avengers
facility so it is no longer signaling
her and then of course she pops up
immediately after it also appears that
the Avengers have no idea who she is so
Nick Fury has never told them about
Captain Marvel at any point in time
another thing is that since this takes
place probably very early on in Avengers
in game that means Captain Marvel will
appear in Avengers in game very early on
many people have speculated that she
will pop up halfway through the movie or
more towards the end but this clearly
indicates that she will be there in the
beginning and of course the last thing
is that this is footage from avengers
endgame there's a high chance that we
will see this exact scene play out in
avengers endgame so that's it for the
post-credits scene that ties Captain
Marvel to Avengers in game on to the
next post-credit scene which is more of
a funny scene it is simply goose
throwing up the tesseract on Nick Fury's
desk so we know that goose is actually a
flirtin with is an alien race and that
Carole actually got her powers somewhat
from the tesseract as well so that's my
breakdown of the two post-credit scenes
from Captain Marvel let me know what you
think about them in the comments down
below and let me know what you thought
about Captain Marvel and again don't
forget to subscribe comment and like the
video so you can enter the giveaway and
stay up to date on everything relating
to Avengers endgame and Marvel as always
thank you all so much for watching
wolf wolf
[Music]